hello welcome to this video playing
drain you let's do something else touch
defense okay he's going for this line
poom isn't this interesting and they go
D for I think this is why d6s maybe the
more precise way to play this yeah now I
have a weird knight on c6 okay probably
six or something at least it's a
somewhat freestyle plain knight on c6
mmmm okay now somehow make some sort of
leningrad out of that with g six boys
this is this bad I don't know it looks
very strange yeah thats grandmaster
sooner Burke hands and by the way from
from Denmark hmm
yeah maybe you can just take it 60 there
should be six then a night move I have
to go back to see aid okay it's not
maybe not that terrible he also this
takes some time this d5 and capturing
maybe it almost has to take no
interesting so he probably wants to play
the night only six somehow hmm
so what do I do here probably c6 so that
after 96 takes takes i can go queen b 6
or queen c7 to cover the beep on it
looks a lot like some kind of kings in
yen very very sharp unconventional
position so taking is probably no good
even though even though the Queen on b3
I wonder how bad that actually is could
be interesting let's let's try that my
DS night f5 to deform and the Queen on
b3 that that actually does make some
kind of sense now it is six now I can
take play d 5 I guess probably I can
yeah that's the idea
hmm ok really isn't that kind of
annoying if I cheek here giving away the
dark squared Bishop is kind of risky
96mm I am Bishop h6 I mean I can play
all that I can move the night like 90
iOS has 96 of course ok let's do this
I cannot reach for them Kim so and if i
take now and then Queenie seven is that
bad they're probably not bad but Jack
it's also not sir I mean not winning or
anything you're threatening e7 I think I
probably have to play Queenie 70 you
might have look f6 by the way well you
might have a look at six that's er
that's a real problem hmm Queen B 6 he
has a seven this is this is bad I look
f6 I didn't think about this one
the author has 95 then this is the issue
okay so if i move the king queen bee
seven queen bee six maybe pull hard to
say now i don't think that was bad for
me really don't think but we have
success syntactic that is so far too
late
you're just taking p7 it's not not bad
at all queen bee six maybe yeah come on
I'm done one time as well so yeah just
eat 700 f6 probably wins yeah that's a
good move simple move but a good 196
check is an additional problem night
here look f 79 f to check maybe maybe I
know where they ate is actually hanging
its that's that's just losing straight
away
hey what's the deal you can just take a
seven yeah okay and that's it i'm jang
can take everywhere but anyway yeah okay
it was interesting resins interesting
yeah i mean i really don't believe that
this can be that great for him to be
honest if he gives me that that here i
mean there should be some kind of
playable option now yeah i just didn't
see root cap six so that that's the
problem here yeah seven yeah I have to
do something else here Queenie seven the
computer gives us slightly better for
white with 94 bday that's I mean it
slightly better really that that just
that that looks awkward for black maybe
yeah maybe it's made opposite colors
bishops maybe I can somehow escaped to
some some George endgame but that looks
bad right here only here I noticed that
I cannot do this because of Rugare six
and i'm just getting killed Queen takes
there is some 37 and this is also so
just just all for the engine wants to do
this is probably the best yes no and
then I just I'm just in a in a bad spot
whoopee eight so still seems to put up a
fight now that's really awkward this
position t I'm just lost
so I really have to go queen bee six
years when the computer is giving
looking at this with the Queen if he
takes now yeah now this is ok I can
always play Bishop age six to activate
that bad-looking bishop engine is on
equal this is actually it kind of useful
they file now equal is probably fair
assessment that was a really creative
opening here it's worth looking at this
briefly this d3 move is interesting
against this f5 um I actually screwed I
mean not screwed up it's a bit bit harsh
but black um would like to go for a five
in this position you can start with d 6
or with 96 d6 is probably the better
option to do it the idea being to play
like this which looks a little bit like
yeah Black has played some kind of
Latvian gambit then white has declined
with d3 and this is not so scary for
black it's kind of its playable white I
mean interesting line but like is I
think quite okay and I actually wanted
to do this here as well what he has got
d for this funny d3 d4 but this is
really wrong Yahtzee six now I tried
this g6 some setup which was some was
interesting I thought you would take
care to be honest and he has sent my my
bishop back but maybe this isn't that
brilliant for white I mean I would
prefer white in this position here at
least a little bit well okay yeah it was
an interesting game thanks for watching